how are you thank you no are you an  amazing dress yeah party dress and like  that for the red carpet to wear the red  what you got a secret going on on with  this dress what do you mean a secret  anything secret underneath some people  go uh you know commando uh yeah no I got  my underwear on you know nothing too  exciting under there yeah  congratulations on everything so you  guys moved to CMT yes we did how do you  feel about them a big move you know what  I think it's gonna be great I think it's  gonna be great for the show and CMT is  so excited and they're putting so much  into it and really what's most exciting  we have new show runners Marshall  Hershkovitz and Ed Zwick and it's gonna  be the best writing we've ever seen on  the show yeah I look forward to it I'm  already a fan so I look forward to  seeing it even more thank you  congratulations and everything  you